America's not strong on our own we have
to actually work at it and that's the
part I hope that Americans take away is
it's going to take every single one of
us to fix this and in order to do that
you've got to realize a lot of things
have gone wrong and Dave it wasn't just
the Democrats that did this to us there
are no saint Republicans right now
because you look at Congress and and all
of this inflation all the economic
issues that started with Republicans
that 2.2 trillion dollar stimulus
package that was passed Republicans
started Democrats have just run with it
after that but then what did Republicans
do after that so first they do this
free-for-all they expand welfare so we
now have 90 million people on Medicare
42 million people on food stamps so they
expand welfare and then oh it's bad so
what else do Republicans do open up
earmarks after 10 years
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and welcome to the first
episode of the path to the presidency
over the coming months I'm going to be
interviewing all of the declared
Republican presidential candidates and
if some Democrats get in I guess we
could do that too and joining me to kick
this off is the former governor of South
Carolina the former U.S ambassador to
the United Nations and now Republican
candidate for president of the United
States Nikki Haley Nikki nice to see you
thanks for the chat I appreciate it all
right you're first out of all of the
people well you were
technically you weren't first in right
Donald Trump was first in you were
second in but you're first with me which
I would imagine is yes probably more
important yes you know I mean look I'm a
decisive person I didn't need to wait I
didn't need to wait to see who else was
going to get in I didn't need to wait or
worry about anything else I think if
you're gonna do this you have to do it
because you know this is what you want
and you know this is what you think you
can do for the country and so we were
ready and you know it's been a month and
it's been a whirlwind but we're working
and all is good what were the biggest
things holding you back before
announcing or the biggest worries we'll
get into the reasons why you're running
obviously but like what was the stuff
that you were going maybe I shouldn't do
it it's always only family I mean family
is the only reason that you you know
you've got this
when you when you know you can fix
something
like it just itches at you and really
after the midterms I was like that's it
that's it you know I mean it it's how
much more do you sit back and watch and
I've always been a problem solver and I
know what we need to do I've been a
two-term governor that took double-digit
unemployment state and turned it into an
economic Powerhouse I was at the U.N I
didn't deal with one country I dealt
with 193 and took the kick me sign off
of our back and I look at where our
country is and I see us falling into
this socialism and defeatism and you
know there's not an Avenue that we don't
have serious issues with and I'm
thinking you know I'm gonna do this and
you know it goes back to the fact that I
look at my parents they came here 50
years ago when America was strong and
confident and full of opportunities I
want to prove to them that they made the
right decision you know I'm a military
wife and I've watched my husband and his
brothers and sisters go out and fight
for our freedoms I want them to know
their sacrifice matter did it mean
something and I look at my kids and my
daughter's getting married and I see how
hard it is for her to buy a home and my
son is in college and I see him writing
papers he doesn't believe in to get an A
and none of us should be okay with that
and recently 50 percent of Americans
said that they don't think their
children will live a better life than
them I refuse to let that happen to this
great country I just refuse it so I'm
going to get in there and do something
about are you shocked how quickly things
have changed for the worse I mean if you
take Trump's term before covid things
were good the economy was chugging along
we weren't in extemporaneous Wars like
things seem to be moving nicely and then
in these last two years and especially
just this last you know week and a half
with all of this banking stuff it's like
everything feels unsettled right now
well when you have a weak president when
you have the most socialist president
that we've ever had that's what's going
to happen you know America's not strong
on our own we have to actually work at
it and that's the part I hope that
Americans take away is it's going to
take every single one of us to fix this
and in order to do that you've got to
realize a lot of things have gone wrong
and Dave it wasn't just the Democrats
that did this to us there are no saint
Republicans right now because you look
at Congress and all of this inflation
all the economic issues that started
with Republicans that 2.2 trillion
dollar stimulus package that was passed
Republicans started Democrats have just
run with it after that but then what did
Republicans do after that so first they
do this free-for-all they expand welfare
so we now have 90 million people on
Medicare 42 million people on food
stamps so they expand welfare and then
oh it's bad so what else do Republicans
do open up earmarks after 10 years like
what do you make of that because when
every time so Republicans usually say
we're for small government we're for low
taxes and every now and again someone
does cut taxes but when something like
the Omnibus comes and they sign on to
all of these crazy things and you know
nobody's read the bill and they know
what we're all going to say about it yet
they keep doing it is that is that to
you just like the definition of what the
swamp is I mean don't tell me that
Republicans and Democrats don't agree on
anything because they love to waste
taxpayer money and they have no value
for a dollar it's why I think we have to
have term limits that's why I think we
have to have mandatory mental competency
tests over the age of 75. I mean this is
serious and then you look at the fact
that our debt is higher than our economy
we're having to borrow money to make our
interest payments I mean none of this is
okay and so Republicans love to get on
TV and talk about how awful Biden is
they started it so don't don't do that
but we can put an end to it and that's
the key and you know now they're looking
at what's going to happen with the
economy and Biden of course wants to
just keep raising taxes but what should
they be doing call back the 500 billion
in coveted money that hasn't been spent
don't put IRS agents on middle class
Americans go and get that 100 billion in
covid fraud that happened you know if 15
of our budget is interest stop borrowing
money we don't do that at home as
Governor I had to balance a budget at
what point is Congress going to realize
they are not the only body that gets
exempt from how they spend are you
telling me if we uh increase the the
deficit and the ceiling the the debt
ceiling every year two years or whatever
that that might cause a long-term
problem am I am I following you properly
I mean look at our households yeah we
don't spend more than we make because we
can't be pretty sweet if you could just
always up that credit limit it's amazing
to me truly and and I mean Republican
can't say they're conservative you're
not conservative if you're spending like
that and look I've dealt with that in
South Carolina we had a republican House
a Republican Senate and they didn't see
anything they didn't that they didn't
love to spend on and we called them out
on it we called out Port projects we
called out the fact that we had to pay
down debt we went and gave tax cuts like
you've got to be proactive and say
enough and I think Republicans have to
realize look yeah we can bash the
Democrats they they have been awful
they're socialist it's it's terrible but
let's look in the mirror look in the
mirror and republicans in Congress need
to say but what responsibility do we
take do you fear ever that the cultural
War has has been so lost that even if
you have all of the right ideas right so
we can talk about individual rights and
limited government and Free Speech all
of the right stuff that the cultural
part of this is so messed up and so many
people don't understand what the real
issues are and kind of just do want the
government to do everything that it
almost becomes an unwinnable situation
for Republican like if you look at the
midterms it's like the Republicans
obviously should have won and yet people
were basically like well the Democrats
are running everything it's not that
good but I'm not going to vote for
Republican but I don't think that's what
happened I mean I Endure 70 candidates
we raise 10 million dollars that went
directly into campaign accounts I was on
the ground campaigning I think you had
three things that went wrong I think
first of all you saw Democrats outraged
Republicans again you saw the fact that
Republicans have to get it out of their
heads that you you have to vote on
Election Day if you have legal voting
times we need as many of our people at
the voting booth as we can eat when as
long as it's legal I want every person
to vote because we need every single one
and then finally when Independence and
conservative Democrats who weren't happy
with Biden by the way won't what'd they
see they saw Republicans hitting on each
other and hitting on Democrats it looked
like chaos we have to go back to what
our national purpose is we've got to
stop this National self-loathing that's
at the heart of the culture Awards and
what started it stop this idea that
kamalan Biden loved to say that
America's rotten and that we're racist
and they were terrible to the Core
we have to go back to loving America
again because right now we look so
distracted and when America is
distracted the world is less safe we're
seeing that but the national
self-loathing I want our kids to love
America I want our kids to start saying
the Pledge of Allegiance in the morning
and at school I want our kids to
understand that this is the greatest
country in the world we have to do that
and so I think that's the first thing is
let's let's stop all this craziness and
let's go back to showing what loving
America means and that's not with faint
hearts or watered-down compromises
that's by truly proclaiming what we
believe in and then our opponents will
join us and then the other side is if
Republicans have lost the last seven out
of eight popular votes for president
shouldn't we say maybe we're doing
something wrong shouldn't we want to win
the majority of America
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell